hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh march 8th 2000 and that was it 2021
2021 what's going on how are you
how's things going with you guys is
everything okay
in your neck of the woods i hope so
the woods tiger woods is he doing better
that [ __ ] guy man he gets in an suv
i'll tell you you don't know what's
gonna happen
um you know he could have some
broadcasting him down the street he
could be looking at his phone all of a
sudden he's doing some [ __ ] evil
knievel [ __ ]
i hope he's all right sorry i'm getting
settled in here settled in
settling in um oh billy freckles has
been [ __ ]
straight edge sober for like a week
for like a week oh billy mundane
oh billy left with his thoughts just
taking life in the [ __ ] face
every every day every day every day of
the year
i didn't take no drugs um
yeah it's actually you know it's not bad
i i tried to eat vegetarian this whole
week
plant-based just to see what it would do
i just kind of you know i went hard last
weekend
you know so i was like all right let me
see what all these [ __ ] you know
people are talking about all those
people on the internet right
cardio burn fat no right all these
[ __ ] look at me i'm [ __ ] shredded
and all i eat is lettuce look at me i
[ __ ]
don't need to take naps because i eat a
[ __ ] you know a goddamn moose every
week i don't know what to believe
anymore
no idea so i'm like all right i'll try
this [ __ ]
so i've been doing the uh the protein
bowls
that some people call buddha bowls and
i'm gonna like preemptive
preemptively get offended on behalf
of buddhist people because that's what
white people like to do now get offended
for other groups of people
so when the [ __ ] hits the fan it doesn't
come on them they don't really do
anything to help out those people they
just act like they're [ __ ] appalled
and then they go back to their [ __ ]
life right isn't that that's how it
works right
oh my god wasn't that a little tone deaf
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you inside
your garrison colonial
um oh god speaking of garrison colonials
oh
jesus all right i got another repair
coming on the house i don't give a [ __ ]
at this point i'm just gonna become this
insane person that's just
constantly repairing their house that's
what it is it's really what it is
so um the [ __ ] hit the fan
no pun intended we got the sewer the
sewer
uh our sewer line is like the original
one that they put in you know back when
babe ruth was still on the yankees and
i'm not even joking so
back then they were cast iron which is
the [ __ ]
um but they put them together in
sections what happens over the years
with earthquakes and the house settling
and all that
um a space sp starts to develop
between those uh where the cast iron
pipes
are connected and then you get tree
roots in there that
are like you know those people that used
to be behind the backboard during a foul
shot
yeah and that except the ball trying to
go through the hoop is now your [ __ ]
trying to leave your property and
going into the main sewer pipe and going
where it belongs
which is in the ocean right i think
that's what we've all decided that's
where everything belongs that we don't
want to look at
put litter in its place put it in a
barrel
that gets picked up by a truck that then
dumps it in the ocean
why should you have to look at what the
[ __ ] the mess you made
you know let some porpoise look at it
can you imagine if fish could talk and
actually [ __ ]
breathe on land like an amphibian well
maybe
maybe maybe frogs like that frog on bugs
bunny
could kind of let us know what's up
about all of this [ __ ] um
i don't know it's [ __ ] insane to me
my wife was telling me
yesterday she showed me this picture
of uh a friend of hers or something and
they had like this birthday party for
their kid
and like i swear to i call this sort of
the instagram kardashian effect like the
way people have like parties for their
kids
i mean it looks like a [ __ ] movie
like whatever the theme is it's like a
movie set
you know like oh you know my kid's
really into [ __ ] raiders of the lost
ark and they'll have like a
giant styrofoam ball like
rolling down the [ __ ] driveway and
the kids have to run away if there's
like horses and [ __ ] and like you know
all of this [ __ ] and all i just look at
it i'm just like well when the party
ends what do you do with all that [ __ ]
yeah you had to make it for it and now
you just throw it out i mean when i was
a [ __ ] kid you just it was a cake
right cake stupid hats and then that was
it
you got some [ __ ] stretch arm a
stretch armstrong
you know stretch armstrong all the
stretch 90
of the stretch arms armstrongs are
probably in the ocean right now
in the ground somewhere you know
some [ __ ] flounder thinks it's a
starfish and he bites into it then he's
got that rubber in him
right and then someday you know you go
to have flounder
cause you're a pescetarian and you think
you're [ __ ] eating healthy and you're
actually eating the head off your
[ __ ]
you know your uncle's stretch armstrong
from way back in the day it's all
connected everybody
um i don't know what i'm talking about
here so
anyway yeah so i've been what am i
entire talk i'm i was so i've been sober
here
like nothing i mean i'm literally
talking like
no cigars no little [ __ ] one-hitter
no [ __ ] you know
eating a little weed nothing
no booze no nothing and i'm gonna tell
you something man
okay i'll tell you something right now
if life is moving by too fast like where
is the time going
i have a great idea for you just to to
for a solution just
be stone sober
because right now it feels to me like
it's like march 15th
16th it's only the eighth
it's like you remember everything
i will tell you though i am sleeping
better though
um you know i [ __ ]
last last like two three nights i got
really really good sleep and then i'm
also taking naps in the afternoon which
is uh
another good one i guess all of that
shit's good for your brain and i'm
already becoming like forgetful freddie
so
i heard like with alzheimer's and
dimension [ __ ]
it's good to get rest and then oh i felt
i went down one of those stupid [ __ ]
rabbit holes
and i knew it was a rabbit hole and i
still did it
and this guy he's a scientist he worked
at nasa and he discovered some foods
that help your short-term memory and he
discovered that
cheese was bad for and in the next hour
i'm gonna show you
get dirty and you're just sitting there
okay show me and he just keeps talking
and what i've discovered it will blow
your mind i'm gonna show you four
simple steps just [ __ ] show me you
laugh come wearing [ __ ]
and they never do and i stayed on the
[ __ ] thing
for like i swear to god i'm like it
became like a mission
like you ever call up the cable company
back in the day or you order the fight
and it doesn't [ __ ] come in or some
[ __ ]
and just you know they put you on hold
for so long you're just like
you know what i ain't [ __ ] leaving
and then what ends up happening 40
40 minutes later somebody just goes
hello time warner you're like yeah hey
they're like hello hello
yeah i'm here click
then you you set your phone down and you
got to walk away
all the way to the other side of the
room
you face the wall like you're in that
[ __ ] witch movie from back in the day
what the [ __ ] was the name of that movie
which is eastwick what the [ __ ] was it
called
the blair witch right you stand in the
corner like you're in the blair witch
you grab a throw pillow you put it over
your face
and then you scream i know you [ __ ]
hurt me
i know you [ __ ] heard me
then you start you replay that hello
hello
and then the click and you start putting
a face to the hello
and then you fantasize about finding out
where they live driving over to their
house
being like hey hey can you can you hear
me now
and you know they know if you say if
somebody works for the [ __ ] one of
those [ __ ] companies
with your [ __ ] answer phones if you
walk up to them go hey can you hear me
now they know they're like oh [ __ ]
i mean i hung up on so many people i
don't remember this guy but i definitely
hung up on this guy how the [ __ ] did he
find me
taking him by the back of their head and
wide with daesh
what does off the hood of a [ __ ] car
next time i call you you're gonna
[ __ ] answer
and you're gonna take my [ __ ] call
maybe i'd take it too personal i don't
know
um anyway
what the [ __ ] was i talking about yeah
so now i got all this
digging up my [ __ ] front yard and
[ __ ]
it's amazing it was kind of amazing
to see something that's been buried for
almost 100 years
and for them to take it out of the
ground i was thinking about the people
that put it in
you know all the people that lived in
this house and took a [ __ ]
i mean it's history right don't don't
they do that [ __ ] a lot don't they
always like they find something
you know or whatever they bury they bury
something and then
years later we're gonna dig it up
remember one one time they had this car
from the 1950s this beautiful car was
brand new
and they buried it and they were like 50
years later we're gonna dig this up
and they put all this time capsule [ __ ]
in there and uh
unfortunately when they went to dig it
up somehow whatever they had sealed it
in there was a leak
in water from raining and [ __ ] got and
car was all corroded and [ __ ] rotted
out
sort of a big disappointment but it was
still kind of cool
um so anyway since
they put in the cast iron [ __ ] pipe they
now have one just basically one
long one now so there's no way for the
tree roots to get in it
which means if we don't destroy
ourselves a hundred years from now
you know someone will be [ __ ] in
this house
off of my dollar okay
and i'm telling you right now i'm gonna
haunt those [ __ ] people
the amount of [ __ ] money i put to
this house i got to do so i'm hanging
around
okay i'm [ __ ] hanging around
then they're gonna have to get some
[ __ ] 4 foot 11 little fat chick
to come in who somehow can talk to the
dead
right they'll have a little seance
and they'll try and contact me
you know what's his deal was he murdered
in this house
was he molested what happened oh no he's
a disc he's the guy that fixed all the
plumbing he's a disgruntled
former owner and he didn't feel he lived
long enough
for the amount of money he was he was up
down up still he was upside down in the
house when he died
and he said he's going to stay here
until he gets his [ __ ] money back
um so anyway i've been making these uh
protein bowls um
and i gotta be honest with you
after about two and a half days i'm like
i don't think i can [ __ ] eat another
sweet potato
with some sauerkraut and some chopped up
cabbage
and [ __ ] lettuce like i don't know
how these [ __ ] vegetarians do it i
understand why a lot of them are fat
because you just sit there and you're
eating i you know i i know what it is
it's actually it's difficult
to you're learning a whole new way of
cooking and speaking of which you know
what i should do
is i should watch jason lawhead's
um i think it was what is it called eat
with me
i don't know what it is eat with oh it
says it yeah it's like eat with meat but
he cuts off the
a t so it's eat with me and he comes up
with all these amazing
but he's an incredible incredible cook
so maybe i'll watch a little bit of that
i need something
with a little bit of zip so anyway
basically
i uh i had one italian sandwich on
wednesday
i ate veggie all day wednesday except
for that and then
monday tuesday i did and thursday
friday all of saturday and then at night
they start to open up restaurants out
here so you know
which is great everybody wore the mask
you know what i mean we're sitting far
enough away so you can take him off he
can eat him gets weird when the waiter
comes over because now it's like well i
don't want to breathe on you
but whatever um
so um i ordered
uh what i got i got the chicken parmesan
i had a [ __ ] rice ball and all this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] delicious right
and uh but i gotta tell you afterwards
i felt like i ate a [ __ ] football
helmet
and the food was delicious it had
nothing to do with that it's just
it's just a completely different kind of
feeling
um and it was kind of making me feel
like all right
so maybe are vegetarians right because
you never feel that way after a
vegetarian that
oh oh that [ __ ] feeling but then it
could also be like well bill you ate
way too much cause there's something
about whenever you order a chicken
parmesan
like those italians they try to kill you
with it you know they're not just going
to give you like
a protein the size of your opponent they
give you a protein the size of your
chest
um and i was taught not to waste food
dude so i [ __ ]
tried to eat the whole thing and i sh
that's probably what it was i probably
just ate too much
i have no [ __ ] idea but uh i have i
dropped a couple of pounds
um we'll see i'm just gonna do it for
for the month of march
i'm just going to do it and i'm just
going to see how i feel afterwards but i
got to be honest any if there's any
vegetarian vegan people if you can help
me out if you got a decent recipe
something that's a little exciting and
you know what's funny exciting really
is because this really isn't like a
vegetarian versus eating meat thing it's
really that i cut out all
sugar and salt and that's
sugar and salt that's really the
excitement
of eating that those two are the life of
the party who's kidding who
you know what i mean because if you eat
unseasoned meat that is as
[ __ ] bland an experience
you know as eating vegetarian but like
you know you got to throw some butter in
there like that that's that's
those are the people like you're having
a house party who are we inviting right
you got to have a couple of [ __ ]
nerds
in case somebody wants to talk about
whatever
right but then you need your party
animals and that's the sugar the salt
the butter
oh that's the flavor right all of that
[ __ ] when you cut all of that out
you cut all of that out and you're not
boozing
you know i just realized i i just kind
of started to realize how [ __ ] crazy
i sound right now like i'm [ __ ] uh
i am on the cutting edge of boredom
right now
i mean thank god this weekend i did
three shows friday night i felt like it
was back in the day when i was in new
york and i had to drive around do spots
i did one out in santa monica
and then i did uh i did two right here
and then um
la and uh i guess santa monica is l.a
and i don't know how it works out here
uh more towards like hollywood right
and i had such a [ __ ] great time
such a great time [ __ ] with people
and you know
i got to tell you though for other
comedians listening to this
i like this new generation of young
people the generation that's right after
millennials
i mean the millennials they just got hit
with a hailstorm of [ __ ]
i think they're going to be in therapy
not working out [ __ ] about their parents
it's about
like why the [ __ ] did we have to behave
that way when we were young
you know everybody [ __ ] had their fun
baby boomers
right generation x whoever [ __ ] came
after that everybody seemed to have a
good time and then we were supposed to
be like
i don't know what you know
but now like i don't know i'm just
sitting there looking at it like the
young kids and [ __ ]
it's like the drugs are fun
everybody knows like heroin and [ __ ]
coke or i'm not saying people don't do
that but they got a lot of like sort of
like
you know mushrooms [ __ ]
what is it i don't know what the f i
don't know anything about drugs but i'm
just
it just seemed here you take mushrooms
man you kind of figure some [ __ ] out
about yourself which is what happened to
me
that's not what drugs were like when i
was a kid even though mushrooms were
around but i don't i don't know
there wasn't all this information about
it and then they got a lot of like i
i'm starting to like some of that i like
that uh that
vibe music with this like
whatever it is where there's no uh
there's no lyrics
and it's just sort of this chill sort of
vibe
so if anybody's got some good vegetarian
things and they got some good
vibe music i would [ __ ] love to
listen oh speaking of that um
somebody sent me some albums i got some
albums here sitting right on top of my
[ __ ] stereo
that i'm gonna be listening to um
listening
some music stone sober like i used to
when i was a member of the columbia
records and tapes club way back in the
day
and i forgot to fill out the form and
they sent me the pat benatar
you know cassette tape for like 11.99
and not only that the cheap fox the
cheap [ __ ]
they didn't even get the full album
cover on it they gave me the one that
has the white remember when they do the
cheap like white things on the side and
then the
where when you would stand it up it also
was white with those
red or pink lines you remember that [ __ ]
those cheap [ __ ]
couldn't get like the real album i hated
that [ __ ]
so um
we are young to heartache
wisdom um it's a good album
uh because you know what love is a
battlefield
love is a battlefield i think she said
it
best and we should she used to play the
room full of blues too
that horn section from down in rhode
island i think providence or something
like that
some good [ __ ] um you know i was worried
that i wasn't gonna have a lot of [ __ ]
to talk about turns out i do
um let's talk about tom wilson's hit on
brandon carlo
suspended for seven games i told you i
mean i was sitting there going trent
frederick it looks like he's gonna have
a little [ __ ] dance card night there
with tom wilson and they did fight
didn't quite get going
wilson's amazi i mean uh uh frederick's
a maniac
reminds me of terry o'reilly in that
terry would fight anybody
and uh i remember fred cusick used to be
he said he'd be the best fighter in the
league if he'd just stand up
terry o'reilly used to swing from his
[ __ ]
skates he was literally trying to knock
your [ __ ] head off he was one of the
toughest guys i've ever seen
and anyway um yeah that hit
on on brandon carla was [ __ ] brutal i
mean it was just
and what's really interesting too was to
listen to the bruins feed and then
listen to the washington feet
you know our announcers are going
[ __ ] nuts because there was no there
was weird like there was no
uh they didn't call a penalty on it
and uh
you know he had this back to the guy or
whatever he [ __ ] comes in he
[ __ ] the guy's six five he still hit
him in the [ __ ] head so i mean how do
you do that right
unless you're [ __ ] six five two which
tom wilson isn't right not saying he's a
small guy but uh but you know
[ __ ] like that happens it happens in the
game you know if you can have teams play
each other back to back they start
getting [ __ ] annoyed
and um you know
the only thing that really bugged me was
that there was no uh
no penalty on it uh but we still won the
[ __ ] game but uh
but i heard brian carlos doing better
and um
as much as i want to get pissed about
the [ __ ] hit you know throughout the
history of the bruins we've done [ __ ]
like that too it's [ __ ] hockey it
happens
but the washington announces it was
hilarious i get it they work for
the capitals but one of the color guys
going i mean it kind of looked like a
glove to the face
is that what it looked like um
but i get it i get all of that [ __ ] and
i'm not gonna sit there and [ __ ]
whine about it but uh it is what it is
it is what it is so now we got this
great rivalry it was funny like
the story they kept trying to make the
story that oh chara we love chara and
he's back and then just these
back-to-back games
and the fact that the uh capitals are
the top dogs
out there um
you know it's it's created this great
rivalry you know and if i'm gonna be
honest
you know trent frederick was stirring
[ __ ] up the game before he was going
after
uh ovechkin
and uh you know and then it's up to the
refs to kind of sort it out or back in
the day you had a couple of [ __ ]
enforcers and they'd go out there and
they would [ __ ] handle it but they
they've gotten rid of that job
sort of so
you know these other guys kind of pay
the price but i have to tell you you
know of all the [ __ ] out there you
know whatever [ __ ]
ovechkin spears one of our guys in the
balls i mean
you know we've done that that used to be
lou chicha's move for like [ __ ] three
weeks he was doing that so i mean we've
done it too
but um the hits to the head man those
are the ones
especially now with all the information
out there of like what that can do to
you
later on in life effect literally be
short-tempered around your kids it would
have been nicer if he found a different
way
to be a little bit of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
bastard but like i said i mean i'm not
gonna [ __ ]
sit here and whine about this [ __ ] but
uh but anyway if you're new to hockey
whatever next time bruins play the
capitals that'd be a fun one to watch
just put it out there um
what else oh i did my i went to my first
award show today
uh at the critics choice awards i got to
do it from my house which was great
uh it was [ __ ] surreal i was just
sitting there watching it
you know they put you in on the feed uh
this movie i was in with pete davidson
was called the king of staten island
um had all these amazing people in it
that i
got to work with and uh so anyways they
were the movie itself was nominated
for best uh comedy
so uh judd apatow couldn't make it so i
would i was going to be there accepting
it on behalf of him
if we won so i was like all right
so they said you know it was a black tie
event so i broke out the new year's eve
suit
the white suit black shirt black tie
thank god i did
i was happy that i dressed up because i
was thinking like am i really gonna get
dressed up in my own house
and then donald sutherland wants
something how do you not love donald
sutherland
i've been watching that guy since
kelly's heroes right and he was
he had on a tuxedo white shirt with the
with the black bow tie
it's like there you go old school class
guy i'm glad i dressed up
so um
i don't i gotta i can't believe how
[ __ ] nervous i was all of a sudden uh
morgan freeman is intro in it and then
they they cut to all of the feeds
um and all of a sudden i see myself
up there with all these
people man it was [ __ ] crazy and then
and the winner is and i got all nervous
going like not us not us not us
and uh was it palm springs or palm
desert what did
the andy say let me get the right name
of the movie i'm the [ __ ] worst the
andy sandberg one which i heard is great
andy said andy andy sandboyg
remember that the roast sandberg palm
what the [ __ ] is it palm springs okay i
had it right the first time yeah so they
won
and they won my first thought was like
thank god because now i don't have to
talk
cause i'm so freaking out i was like i
wrote everybody's name in the [ __ ]
cast
down on a piece of paper you know
universal
all of this [ __ ] i had it all [ __ ]
written out
and um and then that's it and then
andy wins palm springs and then he does
his acceptance thing and then they go
okay you can go now it's crazy it was
like the best way to ever do an award
show you do it at home
uh they they go okay you know sign in at
4 50.
and then like 10 minutes later they they
read our category
you know and you know you win or lose
whoever wins does the acceptance speech
and then they go okay thanks a lot and
then you get then you get to leave and
then you have to go home
so it was kind of [ __ ] awesome but
i'm not going to lie to you i
i was [ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] and then
afterwards i was a little bummed out
that we didn't win
not that i thought we should have won
i'm not i'm not [ __ ] on anybody that
i was just kind of like i was like i
kind of got into that
who knows look at bo billy's going
hollywood
um i gotta go buy a swan dress for my
next one
i told my wife i'm wearing the same suit
for everything
and she goes no you're not that's not a
good look i go it's a great look
it's a great look and it's a cheap look
because i have to [ __ ] replace the
[ __ ]
drainage system in the front yard once
again
once again it never ends it never every
time you think every time you think you
got it
and you think you got it all fixed
second you think you got it all fixed
oh [ __ ] uh slow joe biden you see
that ramping up the war machine
right all of a sudden no the taliban's
[ __ ] but
[ __ ] unbelievable unbelief i'm
telling you they wouldn't give us bernie
they didn't want bernie cause bernie was
gonna try and shut this [ __ ] down
that's why and they didn't want trump
because he wasn't playing [ __ ] ball
so what do they do
they get a [ __ ] another war monger
just gonna keep it going
jesus [ __ ] christ
acting like we give a [ __ ] about what's
happening or we don't
we don't we don't even this [ __ ] we
don't even give a [ __ ] about our own
people look at that living on the street
in [ __ ] tents
all right i'm done i'm done [ __ ]
preaching here um
all right let's get to the uh let's get
to some of the reads here
for the week um
oh here we go live reads oh look who it
is everybody
look who it is policy genius
uh spring is springing as we speak is it
is it me or is this isn't my crazy
people back me up hey this guy knows
what he's talking what i'm talking about
i know what you're thinking sorry i
decided to get all those 80s
setups out of my [ __ ] brain here
spring keeps happening earlier
like we're [ __ ] moving the clocks
forward in like march
that [ __ ] used to happen in april it
used to go from [ __ ] october to april
let me see something daylight savings
time
day light
savings date keeps moving
up why is there daylight savings time
why does daylight savings time keep
changing let's see why is there
daylight isn't that the farm thing
daylight savings time in the united
states is the practice of setting the
clock forward by one hour
when there is longer daylight during the
day so that evenings have more daylight
and mornings have less
the uniform time act of 1966 established
the system of uniform
daylight savings throughout the united
states but why
um that's hilarious ohio clock in the
u.s capitol building they got like three
of the oldest white
for the oldest white guys ever um okay
like savings time
in the u.s why where is it
1916 to 66 early consistent use during
world war one in an effort to conserve
fuel
germany began to observe daylight
savings time the germans i'm telling you
man they're not good with people they're
great with machines
on may 1 1916 the rest of europe soon
followed
the plan was not adopted in the united
states until the standard act time
of march 19 1918 so this came from
germany
uh which confronts we can work longer
which confirmed the existing standard
time zone
system and set daylight savings time to
begin on march 31st
and reverting on october 27th the idea
was unpopular especially with farmers
in fact daylight savings times meant
that they had less time in the morning
to get their milk and harvest their
crops to the market
well why didn't those [ __ ] dopes just
wake up earlier
um if they had the internet they would
have done it back then they were like
daylight savings time is a [ __ ]
conspiracy
uh congress abolished daylight savings
time after the war overriding
president woodrow wilson oh yeah the old
federal reserve act
overriding president woodrow wilson's
veto daylight savings time became a
local option new york city continued to
observe a metropolitan daylight savings
time while rural
areas outside the city did not so it
started to conserve fuel
all right okay but why does it keep
moving up
um why
does daylight savings time keep moving
up
the nominal reason for daylight savings
time has been to save energy
okay more states moving to keep daylight
savings time permanent
oh that blows why would you do that i
like i like that in the fall when all of
a sudden it gets dark out
the football games are dark i like
things to stay the way they were
um you know what's amazing thing about
getting older watching things change and
i'm coming to the end of me freaking out
ooh the nba is what we used to be i'm
coming to the end of all of this
and i'm kind of getting into the fact
that no one cares what i think because
i'm too old
advertisers don't care all they want to
do is sell me drugs to clean out my
[ __ ]
prostate or make my brain have less
plaque or whatever
they don't give a [ __ ] i mean
and the thing about it is is when people
when universally people stop
giving a [ __ ] about what you say you can
then
say whatever you want
yeah your boobs are hanging out you know
oh
grandpa like nobody cares you can't be
in your 20s be like hey your boobs are
hanging out
cancel him all right policy genius
spring is springing as we speak
and it's the perfect reminder to
quite literally get your house in order
yeah like easter keeps moving up i'm
never gonna get through this copy
uh why not get a head start like why is
good friday like always on a different
[ __ ] day like
do they have the date where they [ __ ]
whack this guy or what
uh valentine's day is always on the 14th
right
uh why not get a head start by
revisiting your home and auto insurance
with policy genius they've saved
reshoppers up to one
thousand five one thousand fifty five
dollars per year
on home and auto insurance that's over a
thousand dollars you could use on
whatever home improvement project you've
got oh jesus this is written for me
you got your eye on here's how to get
started
first head to policygenius.com and
answer a few quick questions
about yourself and your property uh the
policy
then policy genius takes it from there
they compare rates from over
uh americans america's top insurers from
progressive to all-state
to find your lowest quotes the policy
genius team will look at all the ways to
maximize your savings including bundling
your home in auto policies
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're paying now
they'll switch you over for free um that
kind of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating
across over thousands of reviews on
trustpilot
and google so while you're gearing up
for spring cleaning don't forget to dust
off your home and auto insurance
policies with policy genius
reshop your rates and you could save up
to one thousand fifty five dollars head
to policygenius.com
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right all right oh
look who it is it's all
zip
you know finding a great candidate to
hire can be like trying to find a needle
in a haystack isn't it time to [ __ ]
you know isn't it time to [ __ ] update
that thing
it's it's like trying to find an
all-black cell phone
right in a dark room uh on a black
leather couch
sorry whatever it needs work uh sure you
can find you can post your job
to some job board but then all you can
do is hope the right person comes along
yeah who's in everybody's quarantine who
the [ __ ] gonna see it which is why you
should try
zip for free at ziprecruiter.com zip
recruiter does the work for you
when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
job sites with one click
then zip uh matching tech matching
zipper crews matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job and activity
invites them to apply
you get qualified candidates fast so
while other services may overwhelm you
with applications to sift through
zip recruiter fines finds you what
you're looking for
the needle in the haystack all right
the the the cell phone the dark-colored
cell phone
in a poorly lit room sitting on a
dark-colored backpack
damn it i can't come up with the analogy
can you guys hey basically your homework
for this week
find a needle in a haystack i want to
hear the updated version of that
um in fact zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day i want to talk to
that one who doesn't
oh my god i found the best person so did
i sort of thought of that jesus christ
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] show came by and right now you can
try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
dot com slash bur b-u-r-r just go to zip
recruiter dot com slash burr zip
rehear the smartest way to hire all
right last one stamps.com everybody
oh i like when they do it conversational
let's face it everybody
taking trips to the post office is
probably not how you want to spend your
time
that's why i recommend mailing and
shipping online
at stamps.com stamps.com allows you to
mail
and ship anytime anywhere right from
your own computer
send letters ship packages and pay a lot
less with discounted rates
from the united states postal service
and the united parcel service
aka usps and ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of dollars
thousands of hours and tons of money
stamps.com brings the services of the
u.s postal service and ups
right to your computer stamp stock comes
as a must-have for any business
whether you you're a small office
sending out invoices an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print out
u.s postage
24 7 for any letter i got the hiccups
uh any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send how the [ __ ]
you get the hiccups out of nowhere
i wasn't eating
ah there we go once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or drop it off
it's that simple with stamps.com you get
discounts of up to 40
off post office rates and up to 62 off
u.s
postal rates uh stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder 1 million businesses
already use stamps.com stop wasting time
go to
go to the post stop wasting time going
to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk and with my promo code burr burr
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur that's
stamps.com
promo code burr stamps.com never go to
the post office again
all right let's get into the questions
here for the week
shall we shall we
get to the questions for the week
all right cheers oh i got a plug here
uh anything there's a new episode of
anything better new episodes come out
every saturday morning it's me
shooting this [ __ ] with one of my
favorite people in the world
uh paul verzi paul verzi is about ready
to blow up as a [ __ ] comedian
traveling comedian if we can never get
past this [ __ ] virus i'm telling you
go see that guy live he's been doing
some some scattered dates here
in there uh during this pandemic all
right
cheers from morocco dear bill thank you
for all your podcasts specials and
everything cheers from morocco
best regards look at that morocco
inflated fire you can play it for me
right isn't casablanca
in morocco is it is it
let me tell you that time i took my wife
to go see uh
casablanca because she had never seen it
so i take her to see it and it's uh
yeah casper blanket right it is there
okay um
so i take her to see this [ __ ] and it
turns out where we go to see it in
downtown l.a i thought it was gonna be
this amazing movie theater
we showed up and it was like the la
symphony playing
all the music live while you watch the
movie
okay i [ __ ] scored that day
that was the that was the greatest
accidental accidental romantic thing i
did
the dumbest thing was i was like i
didn't know they were gonna do this so i
lost all credit
all right dr strange love country song
hey billy mushroom dick i don't know
what that means
hey man uh on the podcast on march 1st
you mentioned that you watched dr
strangelove and proceeded to do the
peter seller's voice from the movie
uh anyway i was wondering if you heard
of the song
oki from muskoki yeah by merle haggard i
have the dude sings the entire song in
the doctor strange love voice
and i find it hilarious just a heads up
the singer does mention disapproval of
recreational lsd
use sorry if that triggers you
that contradicts your truth man
ah you guys are [ __ ] some funny sons
of [ __ ] aren't you huh
trying to take my job all right
translation
burrito gringo uh all right hello
billy babushka balls long time listener
here my name is fernando now how do you
know babushka i thought babushka was
like eastern european for like a [ __ ]
old lady your name's fernando
um anyway you asked you asked well you
asked any
of your mexican listeners to help you
translate i am a
son of a [ __ ] gringo breeder eat it i
didn't say that i said i'm a
burrito-eating son of a [ __ ] isn't that
what it was
um anyway now i am peru now i am
peruvian but i've been called
a mexican before to answer your question
that translates to yo
soy that means i am yo soy on
on
work with enough latin [ __ ] comedians
to know that that's uh
that's [ __ ] isn't it yo soy on hilo de
puta gringo
combarito stay great and go [ __ ]
yourself i wonder what happened if i
said that in mexico
they said could i help you i said i am a
[ __ ]
i'm a gringo i'm a [ __ ] gringo
burrito-eating son of a [ __ ]
oh this peruvian guy he said i am a son
of a [ __ ] gringo burrito eater
yeah i think you're doing the literal
translation from your language
like like in like french they'll say the
car
yellow where we say the yellow car
how it translates i think you're doing
it that way i don't know
all right hope this is where to complain
oh
boy here we go hey huge fan i'll cut to
the chase i'm in a pickle but not really
because i don't really give a [ __ ] okay
this is very zen way of looking at your
problem i like this guy
or a lady um i own a home
in an in a hawa community what's a hoa
hoa
a lot of prostitutes walking the block
there sorry i don't understand what i'm
really
paying hoe for all right what the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ]
that's something else i need to know hoa
meaning
homeowner association a homeowner
association is an organization in a
subdivision planned community
oh god that sounds like a bunch of
douche bags
you know you buy a house and you still
have to go to meetings the [ __ ] lady
across the street can make you decisions
on your gutters is that's what's going
on
you know i don't know jesus christ i
hate the sound of that
anyways i don't understand what i'm
really paying hoa for
so i cussed them out in a male letter
our neighborhood isn't gated break-ins
happen regularly and we had a shooting
not long ago
yeah and then there isn't much on their
part that they do
for us other than driving around and
from the comfort of their own car they
snap pics and send them
in the mail with a fine
oh they fine you so i spoke my mind in a
colorful manner next thing i know
all the neighbors are looking at me like
i'm a sex offender the only thing that's
bothered me about
that is that the letter wasn't meant for
any of them [ __ ]
and they shouldn't get their panties in
a bunch
i'm just sick and tired of paying for
[ __ ] that does nothing for me
so i should so should i play ball and
bow down or should i continue to not
give a [ __ ]
and if you tell me to give a [ __ ]
uh it'll be a long time till i do there
billy
p.s it makes me comfortable when i hear
you say
let's get to the reads here thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself um
no dude i think you should just be
yourself
the next time somebody gives you a look
just be like what was it because of the
[ __ ] letter
there's a [ __ ] robbery down just say
what you just said what are you paying
for
that false sense of [ __ ] security um
i stand by it it's your [ __ ] house
you're not in a gated community what the
[ __ ] am i paying for
what happens if you stop paying for it
they can't take your house
[ __ ] them
that's that's a [ __ ] crazy movie
right there and then you rebel and then
they
they they worry that they're gonna lose
the locker room so then all everybody in
the hoa plans how they're gonna [ __ ]
kill you
um all right weird ass [ __ ] girl asks
me out
all right hey bill how you doing okay so
i'm currently working at walmart as a
cart pusher for about three weeks
god bless you um
i don't think i've ever met a car pusher
that works at walmart
you always see him see him all the time
but you ever know him you ever take your
time to talk to him
oh my god i can't bel i can't imagine
the [ __ ] stories you know what you
should do after this job you should
become a [ __ ]
writer i can't imagine what you've seen
all right today there was a new girl who
is working as a greeter
dude amazon has everybody shook
we got to make the store experience more
more exciting
i go to amazon but nobody says hi
she counts to people going in and greets
them oh
so there's some big brother [ __ ] going
on all i did was introduce myself
and talk with her a bit about my job
that's all yeah but dude you're pushing
those carts man you're getting buff
she's liking what she's seeing all of a
sudden
she asked me if she can go outside and
hang out while i'm pushing carts
i don't know where she asks me if i'm in
love with someone else
ask me if i'm in love with her grabs my
hand
oh boy oh jesus asked me if i can dance
with her
ask me if i can take her home and ask me
if i wanted to go
on a date tomorrow wait in that order
what the [ __ ]
oh boy i think she's not mentally stable
no
i i think i think you're right i think
you should trust your gut she doesn't
look that way though
she's pretty and has colored eyes i bet
she was a [ __ ] huffer or something
she breathed in a bunch of [ __ ] gas
or something like that movie i saw with
philip seymour hoffman called love liza
uh she's about a seven or an
eight i've never had this happen before
so all i can think of
this is that she's [ __ ] crazy and
wants to [ __ ] my life
up i would actually go on a date with
her if she acted more normally what do
you think trust your gut dude don't get
don't get [ __ ] enamored by the looks
i'm currently a senior in high school
and she's a sophomore jesus christ
what run away i can write in later and
update you if you want yes dude stay
away from that
stay the [ __ ] away from that
stay away that is nuclear nuclear [ __ ]
stay away from that nuclear underage
[ __ ] stay away
says the monday morning podcast all
right girlfriend
cause you're a senior dude you're gonna
be like
17 you're probably 17 eventually going
to be 18.
and then what hey we can't bang anymore
because now now i'm of age and you
aren't
wait what is you know what it's
surprisingly the age of consent in most
states it's like [ __ ] 16 if you can
[ __ ] believe that which is insane to
me
dude just stay away stay away um
lie if you have to all right
just you know and you got to go with a
big lie with somebody crazy tell her
you're gay and just say listen i kind of
got the hots for the manager
all right there's just something about
him you know there's something about the
fact that he doesn't have to wear this
blue apron just
makes he's just hot to me i don't know
um i don't know what to tell you dude
just i would just stay away okay
she hasn't come at you with an axe just
tell her i don't want to go out with you
all right stand your ground all right
and then you have to have
to find boundaries no more dancing
outside no more no
no more of that [ __ ] you got you got to
cut the head off the snake the good
thing is
is this is early on in her infatuation
with you
and is there anybody else at work that
maybe you don't like just to have him
walk by her
maybe she'll [ __ ] lock onto that
person it's like she's like
the female what about bob you have to
get her out of your [ __ ]
world and into somebody else's um
but seriously dude i'm [ __ ] around
here but if that does escalate
uh i'd say to go to management but the
way the narrative is out there is
as a guy you're just always wrong when
it comes to women so
uh i don't know i would just always make
sure there was a couple of shopping
carts between me and her that's what i
would do
uh yeah just be like i don't like being
touched
i've been diagnosed as asexual and
my dream was always to push carts here
at walmart so if you don't mind i'm
going to get back to living my dream
all right girlfriend won't do housework
quick background uh been with my
girlfriend for about three and a half
years
love her to death my kids 12 and nine
digger two
we both work full time i work a little
more full-time than her but
uh long relationship loving
relationships sorry
excellent communication supportive of
each other's interests day to day
very warm and close relationship but
he says if she cleaned one goddamn thing
around this house i'd probably drop dead
in shock
aside from doing a load of laundry once
in a while that won't get folded and put
away unless i do it
i'm on my own here i'm not some douche
who thinks women's
it's the woman's job to keep the house
clean this i've got guy look guys
you're literally apologizing to another
guy it's [ __ ] they got us all
[ __ ] scared shitless here i do the
dishes vacuum take out the garbage and
recycling scrub the toilets etc etc hey
buddy i hear you
i just like it to be split up a little
more
or at all for that matter i take a
[ __ ] 70 30 split at this point
you know what's the worst is when you
live with the slob and they actually do
the dishes and then you pick them up and
you have to do them anyway that it's
that's actually worse than them not
[ __ ] doing them at all
anyway i asked her because they do such
a [ __ ] job
i asked her if she'd clean one bathroom
six weeks ago and nothing so i'm just
not using that bathroom and letting it
sit until she cleans it
i politely asked her to get it taken
care of
a couple of times in that span but
definitely not nagging her or making it
a point of contention
how the hell do i get her to start
cleaning thanks best to you and the
family and go [ __ ] yourself
um you said you guys have excellent
communication
um but for some reason you seem afraid
to sit down with her supportive of each
other's interests just tell her just say
listen we're both working full-time
i am exhausted you are exhausted we have
to split up the housework
and here's the deal dude if you would
accept 70 30
you gotta you gotta in negotiation you
gotta ask for 50 50.
and that's not you being some [ __ ]
caveman
um it isn't women have
[ __ ] just gotten over on guys by just
playing the victim all the time
and making you feel like you're this
[ __ ] misogynistic person
while they just completely you know
do whatever the [ __ ] they want to do so
um
a relationship is not a utopia for one
person
in hell for another person that is not
that's not a functional relationship all
right
both people take wins and losses so um
you know and there's a million ways sit
down
talk to her that way and if she doesn't
[ __ ] do it
then i would do it myself and then i
just [ __ ] i would i would
just be upset with her i'd just be like
listen you don't respect me
this is ridiculous that like i i'm
you're treating me like i'm your maid
i'm not just you know you got to stand
your ground here
all right boyfriend hasn't told me he
loves me
all right hey bill long time lady fan
and listener of the podcast love when
the ladies write in
all right i hope you and the lovely knee
and your little ones are all safe and
weathering the coveted storm i mean it's
not even a storm anymore it's just
[ __ ] is what it is
i'm a very private person and struggled
to talk to friends and family about
relationship issues so i thought i would
write
into your for your advice oh wait a
second
you're writing in for advice what it's
time
for advice hey
[Music]
that's me
all right um not only did a female
listener write in but she set me up to
play the only jingle i have on this
oh sorry more music is playing how do i
shut it off
okay um
okay i'm very proud okay me and the
boyfriend have been together for three
years now
and not a day has gone by where i
haven't felt blessed to have found him
he's carrying strong hilarious and we
have a lovely balance in our
relationship
the only thing that concerns me is he's
never told me that he loves me
all right he's one of he might be one of
those guys where it's just like well i'm
still [ __ ] here right doesn't that
tell you something
the only thing uh that concerns i read
that okay
to give you an idea of where we are at
he introduced me to his family including
his daughter
about a year
after about a year of us being together
okay this is getting weirder we visit
his mom every week
who is the kindest woman i have ever had
the pleasure of meeting
that's another weird thing if she was
cold distant
all right does he have a douche of a dad
i have met
and get on well with all his friends we
have plans to buy a house within the
next couple of years
and he always talks about our future
together my mom thinks he's the most
wonderful man
she has ever met and everyone comments
on how lovely our relationship is
i'm in my late 20s and he's in his late
40s
but the age gap has never been an issue
for us all of his actions suggest to me
that he does love me
he often calls me his little love oh
there it is
and uses the word in various contexts
but he has never
outright said i love you but i have this
old-fashioned notion that a woman should
never be able to say
be the first to say it which is probably
ridiculous that is ridiculous
you know why can't you say what you're
feeling but i'm scared that he won't say
it back
what do you think bill am i silly for
expecting him to have told me he loves
me at this point oh my god where is your
self-esteem
you got to work on your self-esteem here
and putting the emphasis on these three
words
see this is how much it it bothers you
that you've actually you're trying to
justify it
that it's you're trying to like downplay
it should i
should i bite the bullet and say it
first or should i just give him more
time
more time you've been together for three
years you're talking about buying a
house
don't [ __ ] buy a house with this guy
unless he says it
or should i just give him more time than
let him say it when he's ready
i truly feel that we were meant for each
other i am extremely positive about our
future together but it
is bothering me nonetheless thanks bill
sorry for rambling
look at you sorry for rambling
you didn't ramble what you were doing
was expressing
how you feel all right if for some
reason you've been made to feel or this
is how you're wired that you saying how
you feel
is somehow a burden on people you have
needs you need to acknowledge them and
you need to sit down with them and just
say listen
you know i know you love me i'm assuming
it we've been together for three years
you call me a little love and everything
but i just i need to hear that from you
you
i need to hear you say that you love me
all right if it's something that you
need you know
i was almost going to say need a little
time you don't want to just you just ask
him like why
okay and then i you know what something
just take the pressure off i need to
hear that
but you haven't said it and i'm not
demanding that you say it i'm just
wondering why you haven't
okay just go at it with like you don't
want to get into a fight i just want to
talk to you
and just see what that does all right
but like
you know being in a relationship and
feeling like that you can't
talk to somebody if i was you arrow so
maybe if you got the time maybe talk to
a therapist
try to find a good one ask around
and find out why you feel like you have
to apologize
for wanting to hear the person that you
you want to be with say that they love
you
and also that you're saying sorry for
rambling
you know um
you know i would look at that stuff
because you know you sound like a really
good person and you should validate what
you're feeling
and in a relationship just like that
last guy i need
the woman i'm with to do half the you
know do some of the housework
there's nothing wrong with that and it
doesn't make you a [ __ ] caveman as a
guy
and it doesn't make you a nag as a woman
you know you just you the last two
people what you're asking for
is beyond reasonable so that's
it you guys will be unreasonable and i'm
out of my [ __ ] mind that is the
podcast
for this monday go [ __ ] yourselves go
celtics go bruins go [ __ ] yourselves and
i'll check in on you
on uh thursday all right